foreign
[Applause]
thank you
for the last few months
yes
all right there she is
for the last few months uh two words
have been running through my head
thank you thank you to Jericho Colangelo
in the Hall of Fame for allowing me to
live with this feeling of gratitude for
months now being on in the Hall of Fame
means everything to me so I really
appreciate it thanks to
the MBA and Adam Silver the greatest
sports league in the world
my career has been a long journey all
this became possible
because I had some I learned some
qualities and some values that were
taught to me by some very special people
that were excellent teachers and I would
like to share my journey towards these
qualities today starting with with this
quality
and that's creativity
and the one guy that comes to mind is my
guy Don Nelson Nelly unfortunately
[Applause]
fortunately he's not here tonight but he
always saw the game different and when I
came in the league there were not a lot
of coaches that wanted a seven footer to
shoot three so my skill set kind of fit
perfect into his system and I can't
thank him enough and
we wasn't also he was also very creative
off the floor and the stuff that he came
up with
in speeches it's almost like pop they're
they're not kid friendly so I'm not
gonna say but he was he always came down
to me having zero Talent on defense and
he
uh he always let me know that and he was
just an incredible basketball mind and
I'll one played it always comes to mind
he always came in the morning to shoot
around and he was super proud to share
what what what's the first play going to
be and uh one time he told me okay Steve
dribbled up all over Dirk you pop
uh Bradley duck in and Dirk you just
throw the ball off the class and Bradley
would catch it and lay it in
sure enough that ball went out of bounds
and uh we started the the game going the
other way but anyways thanks Nelly
you're the man
um creativity is worth nothing without
leadership and the guy that comes to my
mind is
my friend uh Steve
um
I think we came a long way from those
two brutal haircuts we saw there you had
out of the frosted tips you had
but uh you know who would have thought
when we first started play together that
we'll be on the stage together that is
means the world to me and you were a
great role model to me and and and the
best teammate I ever had so you were
always positive you always encouraged me
we worked our butts off at night went
back to the gym so and and you became a
friend for life so thank you my friend
uh next up for me was uh I had to learn
about competitiveness and who better but
my guy uh Jay kids
um I will always remember when when you
came to us you were
you know already a little older uh but
man you are you're a warrior I I
remember you picking up guys at age 37
38 you got picking up guys full court 94
feet uh hustling for us making plays on
on both ends and uh you were just a
wonderful wonderful all-around player
and uh and and you we won the
championship together we have a bond for
life thank you so much
[Applause]
I would have really loved to play
together with those two guys in my in
their primes but unfortunately I had to
I had to deal with what they gave me but
next stop uh
we had creativity leadership and
competitiveness uh there's one quality
that really holds the team together and
that's respect
um that embodies their entire class for
me of 23.
um I'm so excited to be a part of this
class
pow Tony D Wade I didn't always like you
guys uh
we uh we competed at the highest level
but there was always an appreciation of
your guys's greatness so thank you guys
and as one guy in this class aware of
the utmost respect for that's coach pop
I will never forget you you wrote me a
handwritten note when we won the
championship and would you and your
organization did uh at my last game I'll
I'll forever be grateful so thank you my
friend
[Applause]
and again to the whole class it's an
honor to go to go in with you uh it's
it's truly I'm truly humbled
respect this great thing uh if you
establish it over a long period of time
and then you get the quality that's more
important to me than any other and that
is loyalty uh and the guy that
the guy that embodies that for me in his
life is my good friend Mark Cuban uh
you have a huge heart and you taught me
a lot of lessons in loyalty and I always
remember when
when you bought the team and you came to
your first practice you said let's play
some one-on-one I could play a little
bit
so of course I drove left like I always
do and I dunked it right on your head
and
we had a great friendship and
relationship ever since so
thanks for everything you've done for me
and my family and I appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]
career always comes a change and that's
always sometimes difficult to deal with
this it requires the following qualities
Donnie you found me in Wurzburg and you
always believed in me when nobody else
did
so that quality to me is the ability of
taking risks thanks Donnie second
you have to master this perfectly coach
Carlisle
um thank you
[Applause]
you taught me you taught me how how
detailed oriented you have to be to to
win really almost obsessed obsessive
with uh attention to detail and
I gotta say I had to retire I could not
have done another shoot around of yours
I gotta say but
uh but you you made us Champions and
we'll forever be grateful so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and the lesson there was nothing really
works with without great preparation
coach Avery uh you pushed me to become
just more than a jump shooter yeah
[Applause]
you developed me into more of a complete
player and you're the lesson here is
your you made a difference with with
your intensity uh and I'll always be
grateful thank you so much
the next Guy I learned is
professionalism from is my guy Michael
Finley
[Applause]
you were a true Pro on and off the floor
um you let me and Steve grow alongside
of you and we will always be grateful
and
you know I'm I'm still sad you went to
the Spurs in 06
but we've we've learned so much for you
and you became my big brother and you'll
always there for me when I need you so
thank you my friend
uh no one can whistle a symphony it
takes the whole Orchestra to play it and
that Orchestra I was very lucky to have
one in in Dallas and that that quality
was was team spirit and it starts with
uh with the whole math staff with the
medical staff with the I mean everybody
that does so much work behind the scenes
and and and and really helps us to
perform every night
um all my ex-teammates I mean I almost
had 200 of them along my 21 years some
of them are here tonight uh some of the
guys submit 2011 championship teams are
here we have a foreign
of course I couldn't have done it
without you you guys carried me every
night on defense especially and and we
have a we have a bond for life so I
really appreciate you guys coming in
of course uh all the Mavs fans
[Music]
[Applause]
all right I hear you I hear you
everyone hears you yeah
[Applause]
you guys uh inspired and motivated me to
always work hard and
um
I will always be proud to represent you
guys and of course the Dallas Mavericks
so thank you
all these qualities I could have never
learned without the next one is
innovation and the one crazy guy comes
to mind is
my coach Holger
I mean you always thought outside the
box I mean I was I had to walk through
the gym and handstands I had to play the
saxophone and I had to play the
saxophone while doing the handstand uh
I mean what what else can I say you uh
you taught me everything from the jump
shot to how to play and you know early
on motor skills were always more
important than strength training and I
think that that helped me in my
longevity you became my mentor for my
entire career and I will always be
grateful for what you did for me thanks
sober
trying new things always leaves you
vulnerable and that's why you need
protection and that's the next quality
and I have received that from my sister
silke
and her family Rowley Lenny Lila
uh you guys always looked out for me and
you were always there for me when when I
needed you and
so I'm sorry I forgot you uh to mention
you at the Jersey retirement
you know it's a good thing you were only
mad at me for a brief moment and
that brief moment is still going
next up is something I learned from from
two people and they're sitting here
tonight and
they extremely important message and
quality is humbleness and I learned that
from my parents uh helges and J dub
[Applause]
thank you
uh you obviously sacrificed so much and
and put your lives on hold so so silk
and I can chase our athletic dreams and
to make sure you really understand what
I'm saying here the next two sentences
are actually on my accent they're German
so
much
and uh
thank you
[Applause]
all these qualities are important but
the one really come into play is passion
and uh I thought I had plenty already in
my career until I met you Jess
uh your passion for our family is is
incredible you're so driven when
when you want something in life you uh
you will work so hard to get it
um
thanks so much for for everything you
you do for our family and for our kids
and we're really lucky to have you in
our lives love you
[Applause]
as you see so many qualities are and
values are extremely helpful but there's
one more that adds a little spice and
that's curiosity
and I got the best three kids three
teachers here tonight those are our kids
Malaika I'm here I like
Malaika Max and Morris
um please keep this forever stay curious
and hungry find your passion and work
hard I think I shared with you some of
the stories tonight that that I learned
from my role models and I wish the same
for you find your role models that
inspire you along the way
um
it's It's always important in life to
always have to drive to improve to never
be satisfied always see yourself as
someone who wants to learn and not see
yourself as someone who knows everything
already I've had so many great lessons
taught to me by incredible teachers and
you will find them too so remember when
you're green you grow when you're ripe
you rot thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you